das ist wirklich unglaublich ein
russisches forschungsteam will jetzt
zwei arten von würmern erfolgreich
wiederbelebt haben diese fadenwürmer
sollen vor etwa 42.000 jahren im
permafrostboden in sibirien
eingeschlossen worden sein
doch sie waren wohl nicht tot sondern
krüger konserviert wie das
forschungsteam vorgegangen ist wie die
würmer es geschafft haben jahrtausende
mainz zu überleben und was diese
entdeckung für die suche nach
außerirdischem leben bedeutet mit diesen
fragen beschäftigen wir uns jetzt bei
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen beim auftauen ließ sich das
forschungsteam zeit und die spannung
stieg ins unermessliche mehrere wochen
lang haben sie ihren fund in
petrischalen auftauen lassen und je mehr
das eis schmolz
umso lebendiger wurden die darin
enthaltenen würmer aber die ganze
geschichte für euch von vorne
die permafrost proben hatten die
forscher in sibirien gefunden genauer
gesagt in der abgelegenen republik
sacher und 300 proben hatten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
analysiert und zwei ausgewählt in denen
sich gut erhaltenen nematoden befanden
übrigens auch als fadenwürmer bekannt
sie sind mit einem durchmesser von
weniger als einem millimeter zwar sehr
klein sorgen aber immer mal wieder für
überraschungen
sie wurden nämlich beispielsweise in
einer tiefe von rund einem kilometer
unterhalb der erdoberfläche entdeckt was
tiefer ist als jeder andere mehr zähler
ebenfalls auch im darm von schnecken und
wieder andere fadenwürmer die auf einer
insel im indischen ozean leben können
fünf verschiedene münder entwickeln je
nachdem welcher für die gerade
verfügbare nahrung am geeignetsten ist
eine der proben der aktuellen studie
bestand jedenfalls aus einem permafrost
brocken der aus einer tiefe von 30
metern ans tageslicht befördert worden
waren nach einschätzung des russischen
forschungsteams war dieser
permafrostboden bereits seit 32 jahren
1000 jahren gefordert die anderen probe
stammte aus einer tiefe von drei metern
ist wohl nach vermutung der
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
schon 42.000 jahre alt das haben sie
durch die sogenannte radiocarbon methode
ermittelt dieses verfahren basiert
darauf dass die menge an gebundenen
radioaktiven c14 atom in abgestorbenen
organismen abnimmt und zwar gemäß dem
zerfalls gesetz
die petrischalen wurden dann wie gesagt
über mehrere wochen bei 20 grad celsius
gelagert und die würmer wurden immer
lebendiger irgendwann fingen die
lebewesen an die nährstoffe aufzunehmen
und sich zu bewegen sie waren also
offensichtlich nicht tot sondern nur
konserviert heißt also so viel wie
konserviert durch einfrieren das ist
tatsächlich das erste mal dass
mehrzellige organismen die im permafrost
eingefroren waren wieder belebt werden
konnten
bei allen häfen samen und sporen ist das
bereits bekannt sie können auch nach
millionen von jahren in denen sie
eingefroren waren noch lebensfähig sein
bei komplexeren organismen wie den
fadenwürmern hatte man das phänomen zwar
auch schon beobachtet doch dabei betrug
die längste eingefrorene zeitspanne
lediglich 39 jahre auch hier waren sie
in aktiviert und konnten wieder belebt
werden
ein ähnliches ergebnis hatten japanische
forschungsteams auch schon bei den
sogenannten bärtierchen diese waren nach
einer früher konservierung von 30 jahren
noch lebensfähig beide ergebnisse
reichen natürlich nicht an die nun
vermutete zeitspanne von 42.000 jahren
heran doch wie glaubwürdig ist das
forschungsergebnis wirklich das
russische team jedenfalls versichert die
versuche so steril wie möglich
durchgeführt zu haben um spätere
kontaminationen der proben
auszuschließen
wie genau die nematoden diese lange zeit
überstehen konnten das ist noch nicht
geklärt dennoch ist diese entdeckung
nicht nur für die biologie und medizin
von großer bedeutung hier könnte durch
weitere forschung möglicherweise die
frage beantwortet werden wie wir auch
menschliches gewebe lange erhalten
können auch für die astrobiologie die
auf der suche nach außerirdischen leben
ist ist die aktuelle studie äußerst
spannend lebewesen die im eis des mars
zum beispiel gefunden würden könnten
unter umständen wieder belebt werden
wahnsinn
ab sofort könnt ihr auch bei klicks um
mitglied werden für einen monatlichen
betrag bekommt ihr neben ein paar
privilegien ein extra video und einen
extra live stream nur für euch einfach
hier unten auf mitglied werden klicken
und wenn er kein video zum thema chronik
und zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dann
umgeht er die etwas unzuverlässige abo
boxer auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein
video kriegen mich
immer eine nachricht dazu einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meine
schwester karla kick zum social media
abonnieren dafür hier klicken da aber
nicht die glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch dortigen chronik
tiefgekühlt zum ewigen leben bis dann
bleib dran